to me reinvention means taking what has
been and reimagining the possibilities
of what could be
[Music]
when you're reinventing candy in
something that's 99.9% sugar and then
saying hey we're gonna kick the sugar
out of this it presents some really fun
challenges one specific example is our
first manufacturing partner months
before we were supposed to launch on
shelves they pulled the plug because the
manufacturing was too challenging so I
spent the week before Christmas linked
inning potential investors and just cold
calling them I felt like I was gonna
puke when dialing the phone number so I
just had to lean in and step over the
imposter syndrome I was feeling I knew I
had to find the solution some people
were really gracious to take my call but
nobody wanted to try the product because
the company's name at the time was
stevie sweets and so it was the biggest
opportunity hidden in disguise because
it was what made me pause and change the
company's name to smart sweets
[Music]
I really just took the feedback that I
was getting and was just honest with
myself and saying hey how can we evolve
this and so we're not tied to a specific
ingredient and so that's what led me to
the iteration of hey we're a smarter
choice for the consumer and so smart
sweets
I'm just rolled off the tongue being
okay with not knowing the right
knowledge or the right people or the
right manufacturers but just having the
confidence that if you put one foot in
front of the other you will figure it
out that was the most powerful nugget
for me was not knowing anything but
knowing that if I just put one step in
front of the other and leaned into the
terrifying feeling I would figure it out
[Music]
you